okay so we've seen a variety of of
different models from linear models
which are rather simple and easy to work
with and interpret to more complex
models like nearest neighbor averaging
and thin plate splines
and
we need to know
how to decide amongst these models
and so
we need a way of assessing model
accuracy
and when is a model adequate
and when may we improve it
okay so suppose we have a model f hat of
x that's been fit to some training data
and we'll denote the training data by tr
and that consists of n data pairs x i y
i
and remember x i r the notation now x i
means the i observation
and x may be a vector so it may have a
bunch of components y i is is typically
a single y a scalar
and we want to see how well this model
performs well we could compute the
average squared prediction error over
the training data
so that means we take our y the observed
y
we subtract from it f hat of x
we square the difference to get rid of
the sign
and we just average those over all the
training data
well as you may imagine this may be
biased towards more overfit models right
we saw with that thin place spline we
could fit the training data exactly we
could make this mean squared error
subtrain
we could make it zero
instead we should have possibly computed
using a fresh test data set which we'll
call t e
so that's an additional say m data pairs
x i y i different from the training set
and then we compute the similar quantity
which we'll call mean squared error sub
t e
okay
and that may be a better reflection of
the performance of our model
okay
so
now i'm going to show you some
some examples we got back to one
dimensional function fit in
in the left-hand panel we see the black
curve which is actually simulated so
it's a generating curve that's a true
function that we want to estimate
the points are data points generated
from that curve with error
and then we actually see you have to
look carefully in the plot we see three
different
models fit to these data there's the
orange model
the blue model and the green model and
they ordered in complexity
the orange model is a linear model
the blue model is a more flexible model
maybe some kind of spline
a one-dimensional version of the thin
plate spline
and then the green one is a much more
flexible version of that that you can
see it gets closer to the data
now since this is a
simulated example we can compute the
mean squared error on a very large
population of test data
and so in the right hand plot
we plot the mean squared error for this
large population of test data and that's
the red curve
and you'll notice
that
it starts off high
for the very rigid model
it drops down and becomes quite low
for the in between model
but then for the more flexible model it
starts increasing again
of course the mean squared error on the
training data that's the gray curve just
keeps on decreasing because the more
flexible the model the closer it gets to
the data point
but
for the mean squared error on the test
data
we can see this there's kind of a magic
point which is the point at which it
minimizes the mean squared error
and in this case that's this point over
here
and it turns out it's pretty much spot
on for our middle
the medium flexible model in in this
figure and if you look closely at the
plot
you'll see that that the blue curve
actually gets fairly close to the to the
black curve okay
again because this is a simulation model
the horizontal dotted line
is the mean squared error that the true
function makes
for the for data from this population
and of course that is the irreducible
error which we called the variance of
epsilon
here's another example of the same kind
but here the true function is actually
very smooth
same setup
well now we see that the mean squared
error the linear model does pretty well
the best model is not much different
from the linear model and the wiggly one
of course is overfitting again and so
it's making big prediction errors
the training error again keeps on going
down
and finally here's a
quite a wiggly true function on the left
the linear model does a really lousy job
the
the most flexible model does
about the best the blue model and the
green model of are pretty good
pretty close together in terms of the
mean square they're on the test data
so
i think this
drums home the point again the train in
mean squared area just keeps on going
down
so this drums home the point that if we
want to
have a model that has good prediction
error
and that's measured here in terms of
mean squared
prediction error on the test data
we'd like to be able to estimate this
curve and one way you can do that the
red curve you can do that is to have a
held out test data set that you can
value the performance of your different
models
on the test data set
and we're going to talk about ways of
doing this
later on in the course
i want to tell you about a
one aspect of this which is called a
bias variance tradeoff
so again we've got f hat of x which is
fit to the training data
and let's say x 0 y 0 is a is a test
observation drawn from the population
and we're going to
evaluate the model at this test of the
single test observation
okay
and let's suppose the true model is
given by the function f again where f is
the regression function or the
conditional expectation in the
population
so let's look at the expected prediction
error between f hat at x zero
so that's the predicted model
the fitted model on the training data
evaluated at the new point x naught and
see how what the expected distance is
from the test point y zero
so that this expected
this expectation averages over the
variability of the new y zero as well as
the variability that went into the
training set used to build
f hat
so it turns out that we can break this
we we can break up this expression into
three pieces exactly
the one piece is again the irreducible
error that comes from the random
variation in the in the new test point y
zero about the true function f
but these other two pieces
break up the reducible part of the error
what we call the reducible part before
into two components
one is called the variance of f-hat
and that's the variance that comes from
having different training sets if i got
a new training set and i fit my model
again i'd have a different function f
hat
and so as i
would if i were to look at many many
different training sets there would be
variability in my prediction at x zero
and then a quantity called the bias of
of f hat and what the bias is
is the difference between the average
prediction at x naught averaged over all
these different training sets and the
true f at x naught
and what you have is typically as the
flexibility of f at increases its
variance increases because it's going
after the individual training set that
you've provided
which will of course be different from
the next training set
but its bias decreases
so choosing the flexibility based on
average test error amounts to what we
call a bias variance trade-off
this will come up
a lot in
future parts of the course
for those three examples
we see the bias variance trade-off
again in this plot the red curve is the
mean squared error in the test data
and then below it we have the two
components of that mean squared error
the two important components which are
the bias and the variance
and
in the in the left plot we've got the
the
the bias decreasing
and then flattening off
as we get more flexible and the variance
increase in and when you add those two
components you get the u-shaped curve
and
in the in the middle and and last plots
that correspond to the the the other two
examples
um
the same decomposition is given and
because the nature of that problem
changed
the the trade-off is changing
okay so we've seen now that choosing the
amount of flexibility of a model
amounts to a bias variance trade-off
and depending on the problem we might
want to make that trade-off in in a
different place
and we we're gonna we can use
a validation set or or
left out data to help us make that
choice but that's a choice that's the
choice that needs to be made to select
the model
now we've been
addressing this in terms of regression
problems in the next segment we're going
to see how all this works for
classification problems